In the video about competitive inhibition
we saw the basic idea of ​​having a substrate
or a potential substrate and inhibitor that compete
for the enzyme.
Who gets first gets the enzyme.
If the inhibitor reaches first,
the substrate can not be connected
and the reaction can not be catalyzed.
If the substrate gets first,
the inhibitor can not connect
and the reaction is catalyzed.
Both the inhibitor and the substrate
can compete for the active center,
when talking about competitive inhibition.
In allosteric competitive inhibition
there is again competition for the enzyme,
the molecule that gets first gets the enzyme.
But the inhibitor does not bind
with the active center, but with an allosteric center.
However, the idea is the same.
If the inhibitor reaches the allosteric center
before the substrate reaches the active center,
the conformation of the protein changes,
the active center also changes slightly.
I will draw it in the same color.
The conformation of the protein is changing
and then the substrate can not connect to the active center.
If the substrate is bonded,
this slightly changes the conformation
of the allosteric center and then the inhibitor
can not connect.
In competitive inhibition
the substrate and the inhibitor fight for the enzyme.
And what happens to uncompetitive hiring?
I will draw it.
In uncompetitive inhibition -
The main idea with it is,
that both the substrate and the inhibitor can bind.
Whether one molecule is connected does not affect it
of the other.
Let's talk about uncompetitive inhibition a little bit more.
This is our enzyme.
Right here.
The subtratum
reaches the active center,
after which the reaction will be catalysed.
We saw this case here above.
The substrate binds to the active site
and the reaction is catalyzed,
in this case the substrate is separated
of two molecules.
Incompetitive inhibition
the substrate can be connected,
but an inhibitor can also be linked.
The inhibitor may be linked to the allosteric center,
so this is our inhibitor here.
The inhibitor may be linked to the allosteric center.
When both the inhaler and the substrate are connected,
they do not compete for the enzyme.
Both molecules may be linked to the enzyme at the same time.
This can be associated with the enzyme, regardless of whether it is
the substrate is bound or not.
If this molecule is linked to the enzyme,
the substrate will also be able to connect,
but the reaction will not go away.
So now the reaction will look like this:
there will be no reaction.
If this happens, the only option is for both molecules to detach from the enzyme.
This molecule will leave
active center.
The reaction is not catalysed.
It's prevented.
Maybe this molecule also leaves.
The way I showed uncompetitive inhibition
is through an allosteric center,
the inhibitor binds to an allosteric center.
But it is not always necessary for uncompetitive inhibition to look like this.
-
Connection may occur near or in the active center,
as long as it does not interfere with the substrate
to connect to the active center.
We may also have the following situation,
which is often given as an example
for non-competitive inhibition.
We have an inhibitor that binds to the allosteric center,
but the idea is that both the inhibitor and the substrate
can be linked to the enzyme.
If one of them connects first,
the other can still connect.
If the substrate binds first,
the inhibitor can still be linked to the enzyme.
If the inhibitor binds first,
the substrate can still be connected.
But the reaction will not be catalysed.
We can also have a situation,
wherein the inhibitor and the substrate
are bound in or around the active site.
This is the inhibitor, and this is our substrate.
This is the substrate.
But in this case, the reaction will not go away.
We have uncompetitive inhibition.
They do not compete for the enzyme,
Both molecules are linked to the enzyme if one is linked
does not depend on whether the other has contacted.
If the inhibitor is connected, it will not allow
catalysing the reaction.
In contrast to competitive inhibition, in which
the molecule that binds first with the enzyme,
gets control over it.
I hope this video clarifies things.